the Renaissance right now isn't it yeah
isn't that what we say
I'm so happy for him Rachel Vice showing
some love for the mummy co-star Brendan
Fraser oh yeah this just keeps getting
better and better Brendan's successful
Awards season includes lots of praise
for his role in the well even nabbing an
Oscar
[Music]
I think it was just staggeringly good
performance in the whale and he's such a
lovely guy and so talented I'm very
happy for him
ET caught up with Rachel at the premiere
of her new series dead ringers where
she's filled why it was time to remake
the classic psychological Thriller it's
a really simple answer is I I wanted to
be in a story where I could get to play
sisters and I remembered this story and
so I could play the roles that's the
short answer I'm a big fan of the
original Cronenberg film so we have
David Cronenberg to thank my sister and
I do work that is groundbreaking but
hopeful radical but safe the actress
amidst playing twins wasn't as
challenging as it seems I had Alice
Birch's writing she's an incredible
writer and she's just on the page they
were just completely different to one
another Elliot's kind of wild and full
of appetite and ethically a little bit
dubious and Beverly's a do-gooder and
very serious it's impossible to explain
this relationship to anyone outside of
it and when it comes to which sister
Rachel's hubby Daniel Craig prefers
he's on the fence I neither my husband
loves them but I don't know if he has a
favorite I
I love them both you want me to grow you
a baby out of nothing bring it on let's
do the research let's make anything
happen we all learn a lot about the uh
their birthing industry and the
fertility industry making the show there
was a lot to learn as for if Rachel got
any wise words from the OG films lead
Jeremy Irons I haven't spoken to Jeremy
Irons they're very nervous to see what
he makes of it
[Music]
thank you